hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes art and makes
it competitive and for the artiste
sparring today the spirit of competition
might feel a little familiar because
they're all related no it's not frank
versus sylvester stallone i'm tired of
listening to your mouth or maggie jone
hall versus brother jake
it's not even a wahlberg whack-a-mole
we got something even better it's a
scintillating slobber knocker showcasing
siblings and yeah they all have the same
last name it's also a two-on-one because
twins are involved did you guess who's
going at it today or did you see the
title of the bid because what this
program may lack in surprise it makes up
for in substance and sitcom stardom it's
the olsen twins taking on elizabeth
olsen today on versus
in one corner you have mary kate and
ashley olsen the fraternal twin stars
from full house how the west was fun and
like 38 more movies in the other corner
it's younger sister elizabeth who you
may know from blockbusters like avengers
end game godzilla and okay how the west
was fun she played girl in car do you
know how to get to 7th street it's right
over there silly but whereas elizabeth
went on to star in big time movies where
her characters are lucky enough to have
a first name mary kate and ashley have
retreated from the spotlight but are
still a force to be reckoned with and
they have more money than goldfinger me
i get paid in butterfingers to do this
show you guess what you pay for
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
cultural influence round four iconic
rolls and then we'll do a wild card
round that could involve anything from
best catchphrase to coolest super power
to best costume you know elizabeth's
character from the mcu wanda maximoff
has some pretty cool crime fighting
threads but the olsen twins have built
themselves a fashion empire that has
generated enough coin to build their own
death star and in case you're wondering
yes i your host mark ellis did extensive
research as i always do for this show
which encompassed the re-watching of
elizabeth olsen movies that i'd already
seen and checking out like every olson
twins kids flick at what used to be a
video store and i'm gonna tell you all
this elizabeth olsen plays scarlet witch
but those olsen twins they've also
tangled with the witcher 2 in their day
double-double toilet trouble so the
playing field is as even as it gets am i
excited about this matchup
you got it dude oh this is gonna be a
gap i know y'all are saying come on mark
cut it out so let's get it on let's get
this show on the road round one box
office
i have no idea who's gonna win this
match but i have a pretty good
prognostication as to who the front
runner is to take this round because
those elizabeth olsen movies they tend
to crush at the multiplex and when your
movie resume features names like
godzilla and hulk i mean crush quite
literally but let's not snooze on the
olsen twins and their beefy film resume
in just over a decade from the early 90s
to the 2000s they made well over 30
films that were seen by just about every
childhood eyeball in north america the
problem in this round is that almost all
of those films had tiny runs in movie
theaters if they jogged that route at
all most of those went straight to video
and into the family room vcr and so we
don't have reliable data for their vhs
purchases or dvd sales or rental late
fees which can really add up one time i
had to work for an entire summer because
i forgot that i rented dr giggles you
win some
you lose some so let's see what box
office traction we can get out of the
twin tears hey there's a cameo in
charlie's angels full throttle which
earned 227 million dollars worldwide and
a quick little hello in the little
rascals which grossed 66 million bucks
and new york minute stands as their
highest grossing star vehicle climbing
to 21 million dollars back in 2004. all
right and it takes two made 19 million
dollars a decade before the new york
movie and i'm spent but look it's not
bad for a couple of child stars who
teamed up to play one role on full house
which unfortunately never gave us the
big screen feature so many fans longed
for
all told the olsen twins have racked up
378 million dollars in movie theater
receipts making for a perfect average of
47 million all right and the bar has
been set for their little sister
elizabeth can her starring roles
possibly compete with oh my god that's
godzilla's foot the big sexy lizard from
2014 and his movie alone beat the entire
career of the older siblings as it took
in
529 million dollars worldwide smaller
movies like ingrid goes west old boy and
kill your darlings can't even combine
for 10 million dollars total so he might
have a ball game oh my god that's
thanos's fist as an integral part of the
marvel cinematic universe since 2015's
avengers age of ultron elizabeth can now
brag about having four movies taken well
over a billion dollars each civil war
did 1.1 billion dollars which might have
been more expensive than the actual
civil war ultron did 1.3 billion dollars
avengers infinity war did over 2 billion
and endgame still stands as one of if
not the highest grossing film ever
raking in
2.79 billion dollars that buys a lot of
the row clothing accessories
if you don't get that joke you will
[Music]
for now elizabeth's 8 billion career
gross and stunning 573 million per flick
average decimate the numbers from
passport to paris but i'll remind
everyone that none of this would have
happened if not for how the west was fun
where again she played girl in car
thanks older siblings but it's the
youngin who takes round one and scarlet
witch goes up one to nothing
thank you
round two tomato meter slash audience
score here's where the olsen twins can
really catch up with elizabeth they made
so many beloved flicks that had a
monumental influence on the millions of
children that watched them meanwhile
elizabeth makes super big blockbusters
but the critics don't really like those
popcorn crunchers right oh you do is lie
i'm asking i don't know well actually
sometimes they do and if the sour patch
kids chompers we're talking about are
the marvel cinematic universe movies
oh boy buckle up mary kate and ashley
this might not be a holiday in the sun
although that movie from them is almost
fresh on the audience score at 55
percent which is a good start i'm
talking to them like they're still kids
overall we don't have a whole lot of
tomato meter reviews for mary kate and
ash's many adventures but we do have one
for full house 80
that is super fresh really 80 for full
house all right congrats to all you
jesse and the rippers fans out there but
here's my problem with the lack of
tomato meter results where were the
critics when fine cinema like to
grandmother's house we go billboard dad
and our whips are sealed came out what a
rip-off now the critics did do a review
for new york minute back in 2004 but it
only earned an 11 on the tomato meter
come on really it's been a rough day i
just did a versus episode based on
nicole kidman and bewitched is 24
there's no way new york minute is worse
than bewitched none and now i've seen
them both what did these people know
about art so here's what i'm going to do
since i not only host the show i'm also
the referee i used to work at foot
locker well that much we figured i'm
gonna go ahead and give the olsen twins
an even 60 tomato meter average in real
life it's 26
which is better than bewitched but still
not up to their standards and for the
audience score i'm gonna go with
whatever the stats say hey here we go
the adventures of mary kate and ashley
is 70 and the factory is 60 percent as
is it takes two so we got some freshness
and some oh so close films to fresh town
like double double toil and trouble am i
casting a spell every time i say is it
like beetlejuice do you drink a lot of
coffee
you might want to switch to decaf that's
at 55
winning london is at 56
and to grandmother's house we go is at
the spaceballs mendoza line of 59
but it features ria perlman and jerry
van dyke is bumbling crooks so 41
percent of that audience is just wrong
that should be a hundred the olsen twins
appear to at least have a competitive
game here as their audience score per
movie average is 54
and again we're going to call the tomato
meter 60
until the clock strikes midnight and
that score turns back into a pumpkin
this guy needs to get out more so now we
look to their little sister elizabeth
who's off to a hot start why
because she was like four when how the
west was fun came out and it's at 56 on
the audience score but if the audience
liked her in the olsen twins movies they
really love her in comic book flicks
four of her top five movies here are
from the mcu as end game leads the pack
with a 91 percent and infinity war is
tied with wind river at 90 percent with
ingrid goes west at 71 and godzilla at
66
it appears elizabeth is headed for a
fresh audience score average
barely 62 all right that's good enough
to top your siblings so now we head to
the tomato meter for the deciding vote
oh it's lost
it's a mixed bag and that tosses me into
a glass case of emotion
[Music]
peace love and misunderstanding was more
the latter with the critics landing with
the thud at 30 percent look i made a
mistake and spike lee's remake of old
boy could only muster 39
but godzilla beefs up to a 74 on the
tomato meter and end game heroically
flies to 94
song fight so elizabeth is in kodachrome
which is also the title of one of my
favorite paul simon solo songs and
that's at 71 percent but new york minute
uh it's at 11 and it's also the name of
an eagle song that i don't really care
to hear again i prefer new york state of
mind from billy joel and regardless of
what paper you read the new york times
the daily news the facts are the same
elizabeth olsen has a 62 tomato meter
average as well and for funsies
elizabeth actually has the best small
screen tomato meter hit as well sorry
for your losses at 97 and one division
is 91 percent compared to the 80 from
full house so despite the olsen twins
crushing the role of michelle tanner
building a successful movie-making
production house and now being fashion
icons they find themselves in a
two-to-nothing hole against elizabeth
olsen wanda wins this round and she's up
too as we head to round three cultural
influence
so remember how he just said that the
olsen twins were super rich and famous
and then rich again in a variety of
endeavors that's going to help them here
and they need it because little sister
elizabeth has cast quite a spell over
the mcu and has a very bright career
ahead of her so where do we begin
at the beginning full house debuted in
september of 1987. the washington
commanders would go on to win the super
bowl that season but it was the trio of
danny jesse and joey that won our hearts
until we michelle hit the stage played
by both twins to ease the workload on
the precocious tykes the quick wit and
catchphrases stole scenes for the entire
run of the show through its finale in
1995. and might as well put this in here
now i've had the honor of sharing many a
stand-up comedy stage with the late bob
saget and he was just as sweet of a
human as everyone who said and also
super filthy and hysterical on stage
he's a one of a kind gem the likes of
which we will never see again but for
twins mary kate and ashley they were
just getting warmed up from 92 to 2004
they starred in 36 feature-length films
and they covered all the bases halloween
christmas they even went to space
i mean space camp anyway vulture did a
comprehensive ranking of every one of
their movies and found that new york
minute is the best followed closely by
the spooky double-double toil and
trouble and it's that halloween
adventure that still resonates with
adults today i actually know successful
humans my own age who swear by this
being the ultimate october 31st film
forget hocus pocus or those movies from
haddenfield illinois give me the olsen
twins
now personally i'm partial to garfield's
halloween thank you but i love that the
twins making these movies through their
own company dual star get it we're not
only cementing their legacies as young
business entrepreneurs they are also
honoring the legacies of stars from
previous generations of hollywood
chorus leachman one of the all-time
great performers in the history of earth
plays two parts in double-double
harkening back to her famed turn as frau
booker
in young frankenstein that's
frankenstein and if you're still
enjoying olsen twins family films every
holiday season chances are you're
repping them every time you leave the
house i'm not talking about full house
lunch boxes even if that is what you're
toting to work i'm referring to their
incredibly profitable clothing and
fashion empire you'd find their first
line of affordable threads at walmart
and later kohl's lovingly dubbed
dumpster chic but their next act set the
fashion world ablaze and turned rival
competitors green with envy the rogue
clothing line hit and high priced
garments were an instant smash t-shirts
could run you over 300 and their famous
alligator backpack went for a cool 39
thousand dollars it might be worth it
now you might think that elizabeth pal
kevin feige could afford that but they
sold out and wait for it a new york
minute
we're little sister beth or lizzie or
liz beth i'm gonna stay with elizabeth
heretofore has a shot in this round is
that she's still a prominent presence in
front of the camera so the olsen twins
rarely make public appearances except
for an occasional med gala outing
elizabeth stepped out from the crowded
avengers movie spotlight and ushered in
a new era of comic book mythology by
leading juan division a bold risk-taking
left turn for the mcu that won her rave
reviews not sure she was in godzilla
just a little more than the lizard
himself but she still had an impact and
sorry for your loss aired on
what was that facebook for crying out
loud but it was further proof that she
can tackle mass cultural touchstones and
small independent flicks with equal
aplomb
thanks but even at comic con the
majority of people would have to agree
that it's the olsen twins who put
together the more impressive influence
over pop culture extending into other
worlds like business and fashion the
twins were more than just two cute faces
that started movies and shows beloved by
kids they proved that child stars could
not only function as adults but be uber
successful at whatever venture they
dreamed dual star was formed when they
were six and they gained the majority
interest on their 18th birthday now you
compare that to the very public trials
and tribulations of fellow stars from
disney or film and music and it's pretty
incredible what they've been able to
amass in their diversified fortunes hell
they're younger than me and i dare say
they have the better bank account you
got that right although i could totally
pull off dumpster chic
mary kate and ashley you get the win in
round three and you're on the board
trailing two to one
i'm fine i'm fine
round four iconic rolls finally we have
a round that can actually come down to
the wire all three of these olsens are
household names and we know their most
famous characters just as well as we do
the talented ladies playing the parts is
anyone going to dispute that michelle
tanner was the best part of full house
saggit and dave coulier were there to
get some pg laughs uncle jesse was
smoking hot and kimmy gibler had some
great poppins but michelle was the scene
stealer i'm a little princess all due
respect to candace cameron and jody
sweden and lori loughlin but the olsen
twins didn't have to be fake water polo
athletes to get into usc by the time
they were 18 they could have bought the
entire pac-12 chill out dude for
elizabeth her big screen career is still
ascending which is impressive given that
she's already won over hordes of fans
and billions of bucks playing wanda
maximoff aka scarlet witch her
relationship with her bro quicksilver is
one of the more emotional chords struck
in age of ultron as the film showcased
the eye-popping abilities of both heroes
quicksilver has blinding speed scarlet
witch can manipulate reality and they
both can drop their weird accents after
just one movie what happened to your
accent
what happened to yours
so look standing out in a crowded field
of funny comedians like saget and
coulier and sex symbols like john stamos
on full house is a worthy achievement
but hanging tough with iron man captain
america and thor that's on another level
oh and wanda and her boyfriend vision
might be everyone's favorite couple in
all of comic book movie dumb pepper and
tony or yesterday's news hulk and black
widow are way too ross and rachely hey
big guy
but wanda and vision they got the goods
i think i i think
it works
plus let's remind everyone that she had
the drop on thanos in infinity war but
then we needed to make another movie
because they're really really fun i
enjoy them i'm sorry is someone talking
because i don't hear anyone so if he
leaned towards mary kate and ashley's
michelle tanner early on then tended
towards scarlet witch later it feels
kind of even so far so what else you got
elizabeth won rave reviews for her
breakout role as martha which i hear is
another popular comic book movie name in
a different universe that was in 2011's
martha marcie may marlene she also
earned praise as instagram influencer
taylor sloane and ingrid goes west but
her role as jane opposite another mcu
stalwart jeremy renner in wind river
might have been her finest work to date
those two stars have undeniable
chemistry
look out vision
oh don't be silly
and her fbi agent character is so
convincing in part because of her
dedication to craft she trained with
firearms for three months and took
self-defense combat lessons for half a
year in preparation to play the part
bravo
i dare say no such intensity was
required on the set of how the west was
fun but the olsen twins pulled off a
different trick in their many feature
films they became a true pair blossoming
from the shared embryonic state of a
tanner kid into a full-fledged duo with
individual personalities and again this
was all happening in real life and on
screen at the same time whether it's the
farmer kids and double double
i'm just going to call the movie that
from now on because i don't believe in
witchcraft but i don't like not believe
in it either and i think that movie is
even better than the double double in
and out yeah fight me i'm a five guys
guy i'm sorry are you are you actually
insane or the twosome conniving in it
takes to the olson twins became iconic
characters unto themselves which is a
huge accomplishment i'm tempted to give
the nod here to elizabeth because she
clearly is the best actress of the three
but to be fair it could have been
someone else in godzilla and maybe
another would have done a capable job as
scarlet witch
yeah i'm not
sure what that's about and she can
disappear into a smaller role with ease
but come on those twins made dozens of
movies together and they're not quite as
iconic as the avengers to us adults but
they certainly paved the way for kids to
learn how to tell wrong from right and
mary kate from ashley i say you do catch
on rather quickly plus in it takes two
they somehow hooked steve guttenberg up
with kirsty alley
what's that relationship looking like in
2022
iconic rolls might be a tie but as icons
themselves i give the win by the
narrowest of margins in this round to
the olsen twins and it's all tied up at
two to two
i don't understand what's happening and
now it's time for the wild card round
and then there were none
don't worry there's still a final round
to be had but that title refers to the
classic novel by the master of mystery
agatha christie it's still a mystery as
to what ag is doing in a matchup of
olson's siblings but here's your reveal
our research expert mark hoffmeyer loves
odd pairings and he found a potent
agatha character in both the olsen twins
and elizabeth's resume for the fearless
duo it's agatha from double double
a cruel aunt who has no intention of
giving their family a much needed loan
for elizabeth it's agatha from wand
division the nosy neighbor who turns out
to be a lot more than just a curious
dweller the name's agatha harkness
lovely to finally meet you dear
so who's the better agatha that will
determine the winner of this round and
thus the match but that question should
be rephrased as who's the more potent
dark arts dabbler you see they're both
really into witchcraft agatha from one
division is played by catherine hahn
agatha from double double is played by
chorus leachman two hilarious souls who
have given me some of the biggest
guffaws in my entire life and now they
may actually want to steal my soul your
days
pitiful and pathetic as they are shall
be numbered
double doubles ag is super mean on the
surface and that's just the tip of the
iceberg she is a rare moonstone that
once belonged to a powerful witch who
was burned at the stake over 200 years
ago take this all with a grain of salt
because mary kate and ashley and us the
audience are learning this all from some
rando gravedigger
smart huh
but as legend tells it the stone gives
ag untold power particularly in the
realm of curses which is exactly what
she used it for
to doom sofia her sister soph was about
to run off and elope with her true love
but in a fit of rage and jealousy big ag
banished her assist to another world
trapping her in a mirror she keeps in
the attic everybody with me so far how
is anybody doing this sober all right to
make matters worth remember sophia's
betrothed the guy that loved her yeah
that poor sapp's name is george and he's
now agatha's butler oh the expired icing
on a black licorice cake yuck
no sense of humor
meanwhile one division's agatha is a
witch herself fighting out of the lambo
field of witchcraft salem massachusetts
she was such an evil entity back in the
day that her own coven kicked her to the
curb for getting too handsy with the
dark art spells and i killed sparky too
[Laughter]
so after chilling for a few hundred
years she senses the chaotic brand of
magic harnessed by wanda and moves into
the west view town as her ostensible
neighbor but wilson from home
improvement she's not she'll stop at
nothing to steal those powers a desire
that ultimately goes unquenched as
agatha is stripped of her powers and
doomed to live out her days as a local
west view bumpkin so let me get this out
of the way first i love chorus leachman
and i love catherine hahn they're scene
stealers and young frankenstein and step
brothers which are two of the funniest
movies ever made that's the most amazing
thing i've ever heard
so as tough as it may be to make a call
here i'm gonna look at power and fate
both agatha's have game to spare chorus
isn't necessarily a witch from a
business card employment standpoint but
she can pull it off with that stone
catherine is so much of a witch that the
other witches find her
too witchy actually did bite a kid once
now look not all witches are bad i've
actually met many cool ones in real life
and seen nice ones on the big screen
shout out to you glenda but these two
are cut from a much darker cloth and
while catherine hans agatha is
magnificent as sensing power and
stealthy at hiding her own abilities
leachman can literally banish someone to
another world she did it to her own
sister so who else do you think she
knocked out with that stone if i'm the
gravedigger i'm taking the next train
out of town as far as fate is concerned
catherine hahn is relegated to a life as
a regular suburban boar which to me
actually sounds great book clubs we golf
hammock naps there's a lot to enjoy
about that pace okey dokey artichokey
there ain't nothing fun about another
world and that's exactly where agatha
gets trapped after the twins formulate a
daring plan to rescue sophia who is also
played by chorus leachman so after that
for the dual roles all the power the
hellacious fate i'm giving the nod to
agatha from
double double toil and trouble the olsen
twins get the win in the wild card round
thus emerging victorious in the match
put her there sister
what a comeback victory for the twins
and for elizabeth their younger sister
look i get it i have an older sister and
she can still beat me up whenever she
wants even though i'm like a foot taller
we have plenty of films yet to come in
elizabeth olsen's stellar career and
while the fuel on olsen type twin
adventures may be empty enterprising
adults have found role models in the two
kiddos who used to share the
responsibilities of simply saying you
got dude
and of course this is all just my
opinion now it's your turn dear viewer
cast your ballot by hitting me up on
social media at mark ellis live are you
a big mcu honk you can't get enough
scarlet witch did you grow up on the vhs
tapes of mary kate and ashley let me
know and stay tuned to us here at rotten
tomatoes for all the latest in the world
of movies tv and versus matchups thanks
for watching everyone i'll never cut it
out i'm mark ellis and i just got a
notification that my alligator backpack
is being delivered today so time for me
to butt out
you